[Music]
now I've got a heart
you got a lemon down slowly
now Lee's take the memories am I asking
too much like an old country song
[Music]
see
make-believe
trying hard
[Music]
kids
welcome back to these gentlemen's dojo
to my left from Detroit Michigan here's
the body of a cubicle worker thank you
Gary cannon to my ride from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania must be very excited super
excite his pens are in the finals oh yes
looking good looking good big game
tonight Steve burn everybody yeah and
joining us today sit right yeah I got ya
Oh your dad is here my father's here
yeah yeah yeah yeah my dad sitting in
and my dad is sitting in with us because
of our very very special guest today and
he actually is the one that is playing
us into the dojo today yes NHL legend I
am beyond excited mr. theo fleury to the
dojo yeah thank you very much sir I told
you before we started I said I usually
am NOT nervous going into one of these
but a little intimidated right now you
should be I could beat the [ __ ] out of
me I know and by the way let me hold it
like a little your family could team up
again and let me let me say this because
I know your dad this is his first time
on the air with us yes tell them to be
nice my mom has been nothing but
respectful towards you and your career
and everything that you haven't done so
just know this that you can go [ __ ]
yourself think your dad ok great
language pops grayling shudder yeah
racing Bob but Theo Fleury I obviously
grew up watching you love watching your
amazing hockey player and i'll never
forget i had the honor of doing the
Lemieux fantasy camp bill burr and I
went and performed we did some stand-up
and then we got to go to some games and
I got to sit next to you for a few
minutes and I remember asking you and I
think this kind of summed up what you
were thinking what you were feeling I
said uh you know with your stature was
there any guys you were scared of ever
playing against and you said you looked
at me dead in the eyes you go they were
all scared of me and then you got up and
walked away and I was like yeah that's a
man that's a man and now I want to see
my parents unbelievable but it i mean
that's that was just like boom reflex
there it is can you explain to Gary what
it's like to be coordinated or an
athlete at all uh well just need a
little insight
haha it's really good for your bank
account yeah I was always the last guy
picked for everything kickball women's
softball always the last guy now what
you played obviously for your said when
I think of you I instantly think of you
scoring that goal and sliding on the ice
elation joyous that is when people say
Theo Fleury I think of that that's some
of the first clips that come up when you
put his name it it's crazy oh you did
five minutes of research there we go in
front of our guests well save it for
when we're off the air you know I think
all of us who have a long distinguished
career you know this sort of one goal
that defines our career you know Mario
going through those two Minnesota guys
scoring that goal and in the playoffs
and you know that was sort of my iconic
moment that yeah that happened and you
know obviously the battle of alberta
made it even larger right because and
that series was i would say one of the
greatest seven-game series ever played
in the history of the National Hockey
League because you know Calgary and
Edmonton are both in the province of
Alberta and in the 80s the Stanley Cup
went either through Calgary or Edmonton
and riding 80s and so there was a mutual
hate for one another and you know I
remember getting dressed in the dress
room before those games and it was like
we were putting on you know suit of
armor and you know going on the battles
of Falkirk with mr. Braveheart himself
because it was it was barbaric it was
you know when you / somebody it was with
the intent of breaking somebody's bone
or you know I mean that's why yep that
that was the nature of the the rivalry
and so to be able and we were down three
games to one in the series right we won
Game five in Calgary and then went back
to Edmonton and it was back and forth it
was a close game 11
and Messier who's playing for the
weather's at the time put a perfect pass
right on my tape and you know i went in
and scored on Grant Fuhr and you know
obviously um you know the excitement
which I felt you know resulted in you
know in that celebration and it's become
you know very famous it's on every
saturday night in hockey night in canada
yeah pre luta to hockey night in canada
and so yeah and and wherever I go you
know people that's probably the first
thing they mentioned is the goal you
know yeah and and so yeah it's been it's
been you know I had a I had a great
career you know and and enjoyed playing
the game I enjoyed playing intense
fierce you know I was highly highly
competitive guy which made me like I
said when I gave you that answer at
marios camp I wasn't lying I wasn't
lying you know i could tell i can
definitely tell feel that you know when
you're 5 foot 6 and the average height
is 6 over 6 feet and 200 pounds you know
obviously i was way below that and for
me to be able to do what i did Bess
which was you know play skillful hockey
score goals make plays I needed to get
room on the ice and how do you get room
on the ice well you have to intimidate
the big guys and be unpredictable right
they didn't know where I was going to
kiss him or cut there I oh right that's
what I wanted them to think when I was
on the ice right and and that allowed me
to get room and and allowed me to play
that high-skilled game that that I ended
up playing who was who was in your
opinion the best player that you played
against that you really admired well
obviously Wayne Gretzky's my idol right
and you know I've had many opportunities
to play against him and many
opportunities to play with him
and you know and getting to know Mario
over the last you know five or six years
and and realizing the impact away from
the ice that Mario's had in the city of
Pittsburgh is pretty incredible you know
what he's done with that foundation and
and how humble guy he is and you know I
have a lot of respect for that yeah and
it's really cool to you know to go to
that camp and and spend some time with
him and and see how gracious she is to
everybody there is an air of royalty
almost to where he is he's just a classy
guy and you think of all the incredible
athletes that have played in Pittsburgh
you know Roberto Clemente and willie
stargell and the Pirates and then you
Terry Bradshaw Lynn Swann and all those
guys that played in Pittsburgh and he's
at the top of that list right you know
in in a sport that you know has taken a
long time to sort of you know have its
own niche mm-hmm you know in in in the
American market because you know there
was a time when hockey in the United
States was like the 15th most popular
sport right and now it's considered one
of the four major sports you know in the
world and I think that's really cool and
it's guys like Gretzky and Lemieux that
have you know made it yeah it does seem
just as of recent you can find the NHL
finals on a network channel because it
wasn't that long ago where the finals
were on and it was on some weird random
cable channel that if you didn't have
directv he couldn't get it mm-hmm so
she's kind of bizarre thank you for that
side no Carrie go ahead one Erin we edit
that put 923 mark that we always go
absolutely no contribution whatsoever
and talking to your dad yes or we did
this you know he started playing hockey
on roller skates and absolutely fell in
love with the sport in the game and and
you know I played with the guy in
Calgary who's from Hell's Kitchen guy
named Joey Mullen
who started on roller skates and became
you know the highest before Jeremy
Roenick and Mike Modano past him but he
was the number one american-born score
and he started playing roller hockey at
Hell's Kitchen New York so you know it's
just once you get a taste of hockey it's
it's tough to get out of use here in Los
Angeles when I moved here just you know
10 12 years ago maybe nobody was wearing
Kings stuff and now you go down
especially Manhattan Beach autoplay
everybody's wearing Kings things and I
it's great to be here in Los Angeles
because everybody says it's the best
live sport um now that you're so far
removed from the game it's been years
I'm obviously you're still playing but
do you still sit down and watch or is
that like I don't want to go back to the
office no no I I like to watch and who's
your pick this year well obviously you
know you know when the flames aren't you
know in in the playoff sir you know
obviously I'm a Pittsburgh van because
of kind of you know the last everything
about You mr. third and and only that i
am the most hated guy in san jose so
yeah yeah i think if you look at all my
career stats with the exception of me
playing in this field smite division for
so long i probably have the most points
against the san jose sharks and we had
an epic playoff series that went seven
games i think it was in 95 i'm thinking
her and we lost the first two games at
home in calgary we finished like 30
points ahead of him in the standing
right and we went back to san jose we
beat him 92 the game 3 Wow and then six
for the second game and i had nine
points in those two games so Wow there
was a real distinct hate for theo fleury
that in san jose and every time I touch
the puck the whole entire crowd would
like Bumi and right I loved it ya well
what what of all the
the arenas you plain and what was your
favorite city to venture into I think
any original 16 you know I love the old
chicago stadium mm-hmm it was it was
incredible Montreal Forum Boston Garden
Madison Square Garden you know those
buildings were they were unique you know
they were all differently wrong week you
walk into a building now they're all the
same no they they they don't have that
character they don't have that history
you know you know you go into the module
for him and you see those twenty four
Stanley Cup banners or you go to Boston
Garden and you see all those Celtic
banners you know that her yeah that are
in the you know the Great Western forum
back in the day was unbelievable when
Gretzky first came to LA man it was
unbelievable to come here and play and
see because when we used to walk out of
the dressing room used to be all these
famous people that were hanging around
cuz they used to sit on the glass right
and you know I was a huge Rocky Balboa
fan like huge you know because our story
stories are very very similar and I
remember meeting Sly Stallone for the
first time and I was just like blown
away and you know John Candy came in the
room one night and it was just it was
unbelievable this would be a small town
kid from Canada yeah you know I remember
when the first rocky came out played in
my hometown we had a little small
theater in her hometown I remember after
the movie man I ran home and I was like
shadow boxing and I was just like pump
Gary did the same thing after Flashdance
sure what I believe and uh I was so
pumped swinging out a big piece of meat
yeah it was hot arm and then you made
the transition into country music uh
post-hoc ears can you explain III gotta
ask you what is what it what makes you
more nervous a game 7 or taken something
that you actually wrote and performing
it live in front of people that
something that's so personal what is
what is the difference or maybe
similarities even and being a country
musician
why not I think that preparation is the
same like going doing it shows the same
prep you know but I don't think you can
be any more vulnerable right a singer is
singing about your life and and your you
know the lyrics or whatever so but I
don't get nervous you know I I think I I
was born to be an entertainer and
whether I'm doing motivational speaking
or singing or you know playing hockey or
whatever it is you know it's just part
of my DNA and something that you know
from the time I was you know six years
old and you know playing hockey in
Canada I was scoring I don't know three
to ten goals every game in it you know
as soon as I would come out of the
dresser and everybody would be pointing
oh there he is that's that guy yeah so
you know you just get used to it and
it's it's a part of you know what you do
and did you grow up playing guitar as
well or you just always had a deep
fascination or appreciation of country
music obviously carries huge country
town well you know I my home life was
pretty chaotic so both my parents
struggled with addictions my dad was an
alcoholic my mom was a prescription pill
addict and and so life was chaotic right
hand and so my fondest memories as a
child were sitting beside my grandfather
listening to play the fiddle and and you
know this incredible scene because my
uncle had a farm about 30 miles south of
where I grew up and we used to go there
every Sunday and it was overlooking the
cinema boy in valley and river flowing
through and and no matter what was going
on in my family's as soon as the fiddles
came out in the Qataris came out my
family just came together yeah it was
just you know this really cool see her
you know and I always loved the fiddle
and I always loved country music you
know and so they would sit around
playing gold Buck Owens tunes and George
Jones and and Johnny Cash and you know
Willie Nelson and so so that was my sort
of musical influence and and and so
after I retired and I wrote my first
book uh there's a friend of my brother
they used to play hockey and this kid
who my brother used to play hockey was a
phenom hockey player and when he was 12
years old somebody bought him get a
guitar and he quit playing hockey and
basically spent the next five years in
his bedroom playing this guitar and so
he's become this very famous writer and
producer out of Winnipeg and so I called
them and I said hey listen I want to
stroke something off my bucket list I
said would you be willing to write a
song with me he said yeah absolutely he
said but there's one stipulation he says
we play musicians hockey Tuesday and
Thursday so while you're here writing a
song and you got to come play hockey
with us and so I went to win a pagan and
that song you played was thought was the
very first song I ever wrote with him oh
wow and and our dads used to play music
together before we're even born so you
know there's lots of really cool stuff
and and so we wrote the song he sent it
back to me finish and I listened to it I
was like man this is pretty good so I
phoned him and I said do you think this
is good he's like yeah it's great and I
said what would you like to continue
doing more writing so I kept going back
to Winnipeg and writing songs and and
then one of my old drinking buddies and
partying buddies in Calgary uh I didn't
even know he was a musician when we were
partying together yeah so we both get
sober and and he says you know we should
write some songs together and so um you
know the title track for the album's
called I am Who I am and he came over to
my house and we wrote that song and a
half an hour oh wow and and yeah so I
have two incredible writing partners and
and Patti put the band together it's all
guys from
calgary and and we just got off our
first tour and congratulate yeah was it
was awesome so it's a lot of fun I
really enjoyed and it's a great way to
you know get some things off my chest
that I think yeah I needed to get off my
chest and you know obviously the first
album is pretty dark and but that's what
country that's contrary yeah country
music is all about and and and yeah we
sort of have our own sort of we call it
hockey tonk instead of honky so and and
it is it's got its own unique sort of
sound and beat to it and you know it's
like that old sort of rockabilly stuff
that yeah you know that I grew up
listening to um have you always been a
straight shooter because obviously
you're very honest person you and I
don't know was was writing the book
playing with fire difficult for you I
read it a few years ago I'd gotten it as
a gift and uh I didn't anticipate what I
was going to write read into into it
which which leads to why you're here and
we'll discuss that in just a second but
I wanted to just ask you how difficult
or may be cathartic was it doing writing
playing with fire and then being so open
which I think opened up yes you to what
what you're doing here I've always tried
to be straight shooter and honest and a
lot of times has gotten me in trouble
with the media because you know yeah you
know cuz most hockey players aren't open
yes and honest you know very exciting
after game interviews with hockey
players couldn't be more boring but yeah
exactly it's like the Dave killer
Carlson interview on the movie slap shot
yeah yeah you know yep no you know and
but i think our job as professional
hockey players is you know part of our
job is to sell the game yes and so to
explain the game to the fans and how do
you do that well you do that through the
media and the questions that you're
asked you know after game and so i
always felt that was important that we
you know are also selling our game
as well and so and writing the book was
uh i would say at the beginning uh very
difficult because I didn't I didn't know
if I wanted to go where the where it
needed to go right um you know I was
still I was newly sober and so I was
really raw and you know I I had
forgotten a lot of my story ya know and
thank God I had three buddies that came
in and sort of put the timeline together
because I you know at the end of my
hockey career was pretty insane know and
and so and not only that I wrote this
book with a very famous Canadian
Hollywood Reporter and so she
interviewed the biggest stars on the
planet so she knew how to get that
vulnerability out of me and and and
whatnot and and so yeah playing with
fire came out and and and i can tell you
four days before i was going to toronto
to launch this book I was [ __ ] in my
pants because I was like you know what
have I just done here right you know and
I didn't know how all of you were gonna
react to the lookin so there was some in
trepidation and I felt anxious and
pretty wrong and alone right because I'm
telling something that you know nobody
wants to talk about right and I love
telling this story because you know I
believe that there's a plan for all of
our lives and you know I always say when
I run my own life it's the biggest
shitshow on the planet right and so you
know we're all seat we're all out there
trying to find purpose for our lives why
why do we go through struggle why do we
have bad things happen to us and and so
we sort of feel sorry for ourselves and
we play the victim you know and and and
so that's what i was searching for i was
searching for
you know why did all this [ __ ] happen to
me right and and when is it all going to
make sense and so I show up in Toronto
at this first book signing right and I
had zero expectations you know what I
mean I'm not JK Rowling I didn't write
you know Harry Potter nice is my life
story right and so I show up at this
book signing biggest indigo chapters
bookstore in all of Canada and 400
people show up this book side and I'm
like this is weird her you know this is
strange and so I start signing books and
I the corner of my eye spot this guy in
line he's got my book clutched against
his chest his face is buried in the
floor and he's walking really slow so I
follow him all the way through the line
he gets to the front line he puts the
book on the table looks me in the eye
and says me too Wow and that's and
that's when I knew yeah what the rest of
my life was gonna look like right cuz
when i retired from hockey all i had was
a great 12 diploma from vanier
collegiate in Moose Jaw Saskatchewan and
I had no clue what the rest of my life
was gonna look like Ryan I'll never
forget this guy as long as I live
because as much courage and strength
that it took for him to get to that book
signing to deliver this spiritual
message to me and as much as he needed
to say it I needed to hear me too yeah
as well and you know since that first me
too we have had over 600 thousand other
people either directly or indirectly say
those two words as well and the me too
i'm talking about is is the sexual abuse
that I suffered as an adolescent by one
of my coaches and and you know he raped
me 150 times over two and a half year
period and obviously you know that
changed the direction of my life because
I was left with
you know emotional pain and scars and
and all this stuff and trying to make
sense of it all and what happens to us
when we're left with emotional pain is
that we sort of gravitate towards the
dark side of life to deal with you know
these emotional things that are
happening to us and these scars and and
so you know that's how my story sort of
went until I came to a point in my life
where I you know I had a choice to make
right was I gonna die or was I gonna
live and and you know I had a failed
suicide attempt and it wasn't because I
wanted to die it was because I was
exhausted from living in emotional pain
and suffering and trying to make sense
of it all and I tried absolutely
everything on the planet to make it go
away and and and yeah it was difficult
you know it was difficult and what I
realized very quickly after the book
came out was that I wasn't the only one
right that there was millions and
millions and millions of other people
who had had the same experience as mine
and and that's where the inspiration
came to me was I knew that I could help
people right through through telling my
own story and finding my own voice
because finding my own voice which I
couldn't find for many years what
happened was empowerment came with me
finding my own voice and and I can tell
you it's absolutely been the most
incredible journey of my life and you
know to have this incredible amazing
documentary come out tomorrow yes um you
know and you seen the trailer like it's
powerful like it's it's raw it's honest
and it's so real huh you know
and we just mentioned real quick that it
is the document is called Victor walk
and it is premiering jun 7th 2 45 p.m.
at mann's chinese theater that's 6925
Hollywood Boulevard and you will be
attending screening obviously in doing a
Q&A afterwards and it is tomorrow
obviously at 2 45 at mann's chinese
theater did you think that the book
would springboard to you being here in
Hollywood doing a documentary no that's
crazy right I know it's it's but you
know what it's amazing when you get out
of your own way and just let it happen
Riley happens you know what i mean and i
think that you know I I surrendered and
turn my life over the care of whatever
you want to call it and and since I've
done that my life is completely done a
360 degree turn around and and like I
said you know we're saving people's
lives yeah we're literally saving
people's lives and and what's more noble
than that well it's interesting too
because you said when you were writing
the book you had this sense of what's
gonna happen to it what's where's it
going to go from here and then even when
you were going to toronto for that first
book signing you have no idea they're
gonna be 10 people there are there gonna
be 50 who's gonna be there not only that
but our is the community cuz hockey such
a masculine sport is the community
itself gonna look at you and become a
joke or laughing strike and instead
obviously it's done the reverse and I
think those victims out there see a
superstar like Theo and say God if he
can come out if he's got the courage to
come out and acknowledge what happened
in the past and maybe I can do it too
and I think that's what I got out of the
trailer of the documentary which to me I
god I'm not gonna lie I got a little
emotional on the back half because you
see people coming out of the woodworks
hugging you expressing pain and maybe
some sense of relief in it so there's no
really I can't I can't wait to see
myself there's no question that at that
moment and it's the greatest gift that I
get to
see life is people getting rid of their
shame because that's the biggest things
that that's attached to something like
this is shape right and once you realize
that it's not your shame to bear that it
wasn't your fault you know you really
see people shift and change in a matter
of 10 or 20 minutes you know overlong
the conversation last sometimes it's
even less than that you know and that's
really what the victor walk documentary
is really all about is encouraging
people inspiring people to find their
own voice because I know well you know
there's no secret that Michael himself
is also a survivor of and and when we
went on that walk you know there was
four of us that I had experienced sexual
abuse and there was for people that
hadn't experienced sexual abuse that
went on this journey and I could say to
each of us as a person and as a human
being it changed our lives forever and
and that's so powerful you know because
I I have I man Albert I have an
Aboriginal person I have native blood in
me and my ancestors walked wherever they
had to go mm-hmm and only did they walk
they walked with a lot of stuff yeah
carry around all right but their lives
were simple and meaningful and it was
about community creating community
creating teen right and I say that
everybody's who is involved in the
victor walk what we're trying to do is
create the greatest team that's ever
been assembled on the history of the
planet and that's people who have
experienced trauma in their lives and
and I know that one out of every three
people who walked the face of the earth
I've experienced some sort of traumatic
experience in their childhood
and and so trauma is the string which
binds us all together as human beings
you know and and why are we here why are
we on this planet we're here to help one
another get to where we need to go or
get where they need to go and you can't
do it alone I've tried and failed every
single time I've failed doing it on my
own and once I created a group of people
and a team of people you know I have the
greatest life you can possibly imagine
and I never thought that that would even
be possible right right because all I
knew how to do was cope right whether
I'm happy sad mad or glad all I knew was
a feeling and I knew how to make it go
away and that was get loaded right and
so you know when you see homeless people
on the street i guarantee i could write
their story because it's got trauma in
it right and there's always a reason for
somebody's behavior and that behavior is
a learned behavior from childhood right
and so when I talked about my childhood
I use the word chaos and you've watched
me play hockey when I stepped on the ice
it was pure chaos that I created but
that's where I felt safe that's where I
felt normal right and so you know this
has been an absolutely incredible
journey and really you know this journey
is an inside job the answers aren't out
here right answers are all right here
depending on how far you want to dig and
how deep you want to dig that's where
you'll find the answers well I gotta ask
you obviously anybody listening go to
youtube Victor walk is the name of the
documentary watch the trailer trust me
you're gonna see this I was very moved
by it how did the idea for the
documentary come up and buy what I want
to ask yeah and how long has it been
being put together yeah because because
see there's the backstory that you
divulge in terms of the personal
experience but then how did ya in terms
of getting the documentary because you
have to have a point A to point B yours
was literally walking it was a 250 miles
because we're here in the states or 400
kilometers for native listeners yeah um
that's a hell of a distant that's it
that's a long time what who whose idea
wasn't to to walk I would have done the
victor fly that's I would see if I could
have flown that if there was it would
have to be direct if it was a layover
here is probably not i'm not stopping in
fresno yeah i gotta keep moving yes so
how did he come to be that's well i had
a girl working for me at the time who's
a publicist marketer or whatever and she
said you know we should do something
around this and so we talked about a
walk and you know me being a guy that
likes a challenge you know i thought
we're gonna be great if we walk the long
distance you know and would it be great
if we ended up in ottawa on the front
steps of parliament and you know bring
the message to the people that can make
the change right and that's sort of how
that idea came and then we put it all
together and we fundraise and we had two
RVs on the trip and and and so this
there was a guy named Michael Lynch who
had called me shortly after my book came
out and wanted to do the Hollywood
version of the theo fleury story and I
said I was kind of like coming and I and
so he came to Calgary spent a few days
at my home and you know we chatted back
and forth and you know I just sort of
came to the conclusion that I had a lot
more left to accomplish in my life and I
didn't want it to be solely about hockey
I wanted it to be you know more bigger
right and so we put the victor walk
together and I phoned him and I said hey
listen we're going on this walk and I
said I think it would be a great
opportunity for us that
document the whole thing and you know he
jumped on board and and the most amazing
thing is that Michael walked the whole
entire walk backwards filming us I was
just gonna ask ya the cameraman in the
in the minivan going along like but
you're actually doing it with gear oh my
god yeah with that camera and a GoPro
that's how we filmed the documentary oh
wow and you know it was it was unlike
the first day we had this guy actually
he walked here from ok salut staying in
San Diego so the first day on this walk
we started it at the child abuse
monument in Toronto and this guy has
this monument in his front yard and
that's where he displays it and he came
on the walk with us and told this like
incredible story about his life like he
was abuse from the time he was born
until you know and he was telling us his
story and so the first day was you know
we walked the whole entire walk on
concrete because we were in Toronto
we're at City and and then this dr. Mike
showed up and told this like
unbelievable story about his life and we
were all going at the end of the day
like our feet were like blistered and
raw and sore and we're all sitting in
the Winnebago we go we got nine more of
these to go you know we're like what the
hell have we done here yeah I know but
as we went along you know people would
literally pull up in their cars get out
of their cars their heads would be down
that uh and they come up to me and I
grabbed him and I'd hug them and and
then I just listened to their story and
then they would leave leave us and their
heads would be out up their eyes would
be brighter their their mannerisms would
be different and not inspired us to just
keep going keep going that was your fuel
yeah it was unbelievable cuz we were
exhausted like you get a little angry
that they were driving off in the car
and you were still walking
we just get a ride to the next pit stop
and there was another scene when
remember those kids that gave us they
gave us like they were poor like we were
walking in the country like an these
through these towns and places and and
these little kids came up to us and they
had saved all of their money and their
clothes were all ragged and torn up and
they gave us a jar of the money that
I'll say it was just like and it was
like every day it was like that's
ultimately who you doing it for it yeah
I mean you're now in some way it sits
redemptive that it's the children that
are unbelievable holly is unbelievable
what was the most difficult aspect in
terms of making a documentary film or
this particular film for you yourself as
an individual well I didn't do much
other than you know walk and and and
tell tell the story but it's really
Michael who you know did an unbelievable
job of putting it all together because I
don't know how many hours of video did
you have to go through yeah like he must
have had a thousand hours that yet the
gold right right through all the stories
I'm sure yeah and put it put this story
all together so it actually made sense
and then the cinematography the sound
you know everything you know came
together so you know when you have
somebody that cares that much about a
project you know that's what you get
right you get you get powerful you get
in your face you know like god damn and
take a look at this [ __ ] right as it's
happening that Jeff gave you [ __ ] out of
me that's happening every second of
every hour of every day all day long
kids are being abused right everywhere
not not only sexually but emotionally
physically you know this is the biggest
epidemic on the planet there is nothing
that I've come across that is any bigger
than this and I don't know why we refuse
to put it in the spotlight yeah you know
and in the movie spotlight yeah that was
a great start but this documentary even
goes deeper then what then what
Hollywood try to expose and as we know
Hollywood's been messing around with
kids for years yeah I was you know say
this is corey feldman had a book come
out I think a year ago and tried to put
a magnifying glass to the town itself
and I don't think it was as I don't
think people took it as seriously as
they could have um exactly said it's the
biggest problem in Hollywood and after
the biggest problem in society period
yeah period you know and and it's really
disappointing because we're better than
that if I may speak of it I was watching
The Wizard of Oz with my granddaughter
yesterday and I can't look at Judy
Garland and not be horrified at what
they did to her yeah it was horrible and
in your right and it is this town part
partly to blame but if you think about
it you wouldn't have gotten the
notoriety if it wasn't for your NHL
career there's no don't now your NHL
career has grown exponentially because
of the good you're trying to do yeah
most guys that leave the NHL they go
home and their big deal on the town and
they play some adult hockey and this and
that and the other thing and they're
forgotten I think this is a fabulous
thing thank you thank you very much yeah
because it's one thing to you know be a
hero on the ice and it's you know it's
it's something fun it's communal but you
truly are becoming a hero and a
lightning rod for all the survivors but
also the subject matter and getting it
out there and hoping that people become
more aware of it there's no question and
and you know I wrote a second book to
follow it up called conversations with a
rattlesnake is what the book is called
and I wrote it with a neuro scientist
and who's proud
one of the most brilliant women woman
that I've ever come across in my life
who has humility and compassion and and
is incredibly bright and as we were
writing the book you know I realized for
core beliefs i had about myself because
of my experience and and on a bigger
scale i would say most of us who've had
a traumatic experience in her childhood
feel this way abandoned and neglected
not good enough not lovable and do i
even exist in the world this is what we
learn right and that becomes the core of
who we are and what we believe in
ourselves until we have that sort of you
know the lightbulb moment where we go
you know what I don't have to feel that
way about myself anymore you know I'm an
adult now and I can change and I can
actually change my brain I can rewire my
brain to think about myself in a
different way and and that was that's
sort of the journey in the process that
I've been on but I've also been
documenting the change right and we have
a great saying in the program of
Alcoholics Anonymous or narcotics
anonymous or cocaine and arms I belong
to all the eight groups right so you
know that's just the way it is yeah I'm
a triple a yeah and so we have a saying
it's its attraction rather than
promotion and so by me sort of being out
there documenting my life and people
have seen the change and that attraction
brings them to me which then creates
conversation right right you know and
that's really what it's all about you
know we're in Hollywood with the biggest
egos on the planet right here in
Hollywood right here in this room well
guess what guess what
you cannot lead anybody with eagle right
impossible you lead with humility and
compassion right and one of the greatest
things that I get to do now is I speak
in maximum security prisons now to the
baddest dudes on the planet rapists
murderers child molesters all this stuff
and you know what those guys have taught
me they've taught me compassion yeah
they really have you know because as I'm
speaking to all these guys you know I
look I look at them in the eye and I see
myself 10 years ago rah 10 years ago and
I go holy [ __ ] have I come long ways
yeah and and so there's a sense of pride
there's a sense of I need to continue
this journey why is because i have now i
have access to people i have access to
people and i have access to change
people's lives and attitudes and and
stigmas right and and what people don't
realize and don't understand is they
think addiction lives in its own box
trauma lives in its own box and mental
health lives in its own box well guess
what they all live in the same house
right trauma happens leaves us with
emotional pain and how do we deal with
that emotional pain while we we drink
too much we eat too much we work too
much you know these are all addictions
that people don't know right that
they're actually doing because of their
experience that they've had in childhood
where they experience for all and
traumas is not sexual abuse it's part of
it but if traumas bullying traumas a
death in the family trauma is divorce
you know trauma comes in all shapes
sizes and forms which causes us you know
to act out because we're an emotional
pain right you know the most insecure
person on the planet
is the bully right yes why he's doing
what is doing right and you know and so
you know mental health is also a huge
epidemic on on this planet to you know
and and you know what the US being at
war for the last how many years you know
we've got veterans coming back who
who've experienced incredible trauma
yeah right and so it's okay to talk
about it you have you have to talk about
it you cannot internalize it right
because if you internalize it it turns
into disease cancer diabetes you name it
because the trauma has to go somewhere
in your body right and the trauma sits
in a particular part of your body and it
turns into disease right so you know
this is big like this is huge trauma
affects us in all different ways and
shapes and forms and we need to be
allowed we need to be given permission
you know like I'm addicted to CNN right
now because it's like in Canada it's the
greatest reality TV show on the planet
right and not one candidate has
mentioned the mental health right at all
and I'm like flabbergasted at the fact
that nobody who's in a position of
leadership would talk like refuses to
talk about this right well I'm sure that
they're in bed with the pharmaceutical
companies sooners pepper and all these
because my brother actually is a vet who
came back from Iraq and the government
solution was to pepper him up with pills
and he had lost i think a friend or two
who went down the butt down the rabbit
hole and ended up killing themselves
came back it never came back and my
brother one day just decided I'm gonna
flush he's down the toilet this is not
my route and now he's in programs that
are helping him through camaraderie
friendship telling human being Munich
ating young can I bring my canned
insect day you mind switching up for one
sex we can ask Mike just as we near
towards the finish line I want to get
him in here so we can ask him a few
questions as well and Mike you directed
is that correct directed edited you've
not even walked I didn't edit this one
paul gordon edited this one i directed
what is produced it ariel directed
produced and i was a cinematographer and
did you come up with the with the idea
to approach theo and say hey let's do
this together or how did you get
involved yeah yeah no uh basically I I
was hitting a low of Mike my time my
career has a filmmaker and a friend of
mine just told me I needed to do
something I believed in mm-hmm so I just
started playing hockey ganks my brother
done intervention with me because I
taken a got to focus on work we're back
to playing hockey and I was going to
write a narrative film and of course I'm
gonna go to do YouTube to do research I
look up my favorite hockey player Theo
watching his videos and then I
discovered he just dropped a book like a
month ago right you know and I didn't
know about the abuse I remember when I
was in Chicago kind of hearing about it
but you know you hear about the
whisperings and you don't believe it
like I'll whatever and then I reached
out to his team at the time and tried to
get ahold of them spoke to them they
like me i was able to talk to Theo we
connected and about a year later we
finally met at his place like you
mentioned and we were going to do a
movie version of it and i wrote a full
feature screenplay and then as you seen
the trailer that's when Graham James
only got two years Ryan so right when he
got two years that's when Theon them you
know he that's when he went back into
therapy because he wasn't in therapy at
that time so he went back into therapy
think that's when he met Kimber noon and
then he's like let's pause this movie
you know and so he paused the film and
basically yeah he gave me a calling and
kind of you know we kept his friends and
kept in touch he gave me a call and told
me what he was doing he told me he was
doing this Victor walk and I said well
maybe this is the most important thing
that's in your life right now so maybe
what if we docked you were gonna do the
walk yeah just gonna do and we're gonna
do it anyways right like the walk was
okay but I yeah it was already he was
already do I walks the walk and only
when I first met him you know even
years before that he had already
designed the Vittra walk t-shirt he you
know after I first met him a month later
he had the victory walk tattoo on his
arm so this was like all unfolding right
as when we were even writing the feature
so but once he was doing the walk I was
like this is the most important than
your life right now how about what let's
film is this document this and he goes
yeah let's do it so then I flew out and
it at first man it was you know I mean
if I like I was 17 again you know I had
I had audio in my pouch and I'm shooting
at the canon 7d yeah you know I'd love
up Theo and then I had to go and bro on
my other hand so I get two angles and
luckily though I had Paul Gordon who
came on he came on and became my
producing partner in this and the editor
on this at least when I got back after
after the 20 mile walk yeah i was able
to you know give him all the footage so
he could help me go through it all
together and how long did it take to go
through all that footage because i'm
sure with so many stories there's so
many impactful stories that you say we
gotta keep but there's only just so much
time in the film right yeah so I want to
say we probably did like five months
during the first rough-cut mm-hmm and
then after that first rough-cut i
actually had Paul movies I debate into
my house and we probably another like I
basically the ones like we need to
rewatch all the footage again like raw
and weary watched all of it and then the
first rough-cut was only 58 minutes and
Theo saw that first rough-cut and then
after that first rough-cut we have to
click the raw footage we made it 90
minutes we just don't like to have an 89
be rounded up so yeah you know we end up
getting it up to eighty nine minutes and
then right we finished we like finish
the movie it was done you know I get a
call from Zoran who's like a man we got
a second walk you gotta fly out of it
and so I called everyone up like hey I
know we just finished it called a
composer call a narc you post who did
all it will hook this up with our all
our sound mix and design clothes so I
know we just finished everything but I
need to go shoot the second walk I think
we're gonna add this like update section
well so then in July of 2015 we shot the
second walk okay we could have kind of
an update because when i was doing test
screenings of the daily cup people would
always ask did he do another walk
yes he did another walk so now they can
ask is he still walking yeah so we walk
when we pick a province every year yeah
and we walk across it so this year we're
gonna do my home province so we're
starting in my hometown and we're
walking to Winnipeg which is 400 miles
this time oh wow wow yeah and I was just
thinking in my head oh maybe I'll Joe
and then I heard for hahaha meet you
there I meet you you can do the last day
yeah yeah I'll hold the scissors had a
thing again you guys 400-mile now how
long does it take by the weight you
walked one if we've sort of changed it
because the first walk was so grueling
and demanding right we were like kind of
looking at each other going we don't
really want to do that again yeah and so
it's more of a victor walk rally so so
we'll walk 20 to 30 kilometres during
the day okay over a 5-day period but
we'll stop in little towns and we'll do
rallies where you know will come in with
rtm you know will provide resources I'll
say a little speech you know that um
then we'll go to the next town just to
you know to boost that awareness that
hey the breaking free foundation which
is what we've created from the victor
walk is here and we have resources and
we have you know incredible following in
social media we got bloggers we got
everything going on and so and so we
just want to let people know but really
what we do is you most people can't
afford professional help ok so what the
breaking free foundation does is you can
write to us for a therapy grant and if
you're approved we will pay for your
first six sessions Oh fashional therapy
and we'll hook you up with the therapist
as well and we got a donation last year
of a hundred thousand dollars to sort of
get the program going and so we've had
our first four people go through the
program and I'll congratulate and so
yeah so we're as we move forward will be
doing more fundraising part of the
victor walk this year will you'll be
able to donate to us and and
and it all goes to people who need help
when is this one scheduled for when is
the victor walk this year scheduled for
july twenty third ya think july twenty
ok yeah it is that you're hoping that is
that become an annual event right yeah
i'm gonna try and hit every province and
in canada over because there's ten of
them over over a ten-year period and not
only that would he's also not mentioning
is so he does his walk where he changes
but there's other walks access to walks
happening all over that they keep
buildings that like other people who
become advocates who may be walked in
the first walk like left bridge and
Toronto's there's other walk still
happening as well i think anyone can go
to the victor walk calm and sign up to
bring a walk to their community where
they could host got one in New York this
year oh wow oh nice yeah so well just
real quick so so breaking free how do
people find these is also so we have
Victor walk calm to walk calm we have
the breaking free foundation dot CA ok
um obviously Victor walk doc calm calm
so there's we're out there and obviously
the documentary is going to be showing
here in LA tomorrow but where can people
see it uh that are listening at host
premier yeah well uh after the world
premiere right we'll start shopping into
distributors okay so we're still in the
middle of kind of figuring out what our
distribution situation will be okay but
definitely you know I see there late
this year or early next year as far as
distribution probably might hit a couple
you know you want to hear the problem
though they're gonna want more of this
year's Victor walk in it so you're gonna
have to keep updated it's gonna be an
eight hour film that are we you know we
make sure you put it without 16 footage
in there are we can just periscope it
yes there you go there you go so may I
ask you as a filmmaker what has been the
most gratifying aspect for you
personally knowing that you're going to
see your film premiere tomorrow at
mann's chinese yeah it's in Hollywood
that's that's unbelievable how what's
going through your head oh um I mean I'm
stoked at theos here I'm stoked that
Zorin's here
her you know I had such a special time
with both of these guys in the walk and
most of all is when we've done the test
screenings and the best part about
Victor walk documentary is that it takes
you right to the walk you feel like
you're on the walk with us you know I
tried to avoid talking head interviews
and made people like talking on the walk
so they're walking so I think the
biggest thing is when we've had people
come and watch it they share their story
you're just like on the walk so talking
about the whole message of keeping the
conversation going with this film unlike
I say another movie that maybe you make
a narrative that has entered you know
whatever you get to really feel like
you've helped someone you get to feel
like it is another therapy tool that
like keep saying something going so it's
incredible that it is at the the Chinese
Theater is incredible to have Theo here
and was to be more incredible is going
to be at the QA is the things that
people are going to say to Theo the
things that people not are they going to
say but they might say in front of a
room full of people that they're sitting
next to when normally they might have
wanted to just tell him privately so for
me that's gonna be the most gratifying
experience is to hear people like they
did in the walk come out for the first
time well but it was like what Theo said
early when he went to the first book
signing in Toronto is that first me too
that really put it in perspective like
oh I'm doing the right thing like this
is really why I did the book right which
is you know what would you love for your
legacy to be like what what's kind of
that like what what what's your overall
thought on that I just want to be
remembered as a good teammate that's it
you know well it seems like you're a
great teammate to humanity because of
what it is you're doing it cites I'm not
doing this because I want to be here oh
I'm not doing this for I'm doing it
because then the more I help people the
more I heal my own self and that's you
know that's why that's why we do this
yeah it is is I've learned more about my
life in the last seven years then I
added at any point in my life and and it
was it was only because every night
before I go to bed I pray for
willingness and the willingness is
to put somebody in front of me every day
who's had the same experience right that
I've had and I've never been felled once
in seven years there's that one either
somebody's emailing me or twittering me
facebooking me or just a chance meeting
on the street right is that's what it's
all about and I and I and I can't say
enough that if you get in that headspace
you get in that mind space how much it's
going to improve your own life more than
anything else right is you know it's
funny the subject that you usually get
involved in is the thing that you need
to work on the most right and so you
know that's been my experience and
that's been experience of everybody you
know and and it's absolutely just been
unbelievable incredible and you know I'm
from Russell Manitoban I'm in Los
Angeles California and there there's a
documentary about what we're doing like
that yeah how does that happen right any
what I mean but if you you know thoughts
become things and so you put it out in
the universe it's going to come back and
when it comes back it's going to be
directly in line with what your purpose
is always you know and that's the that's
the power that this thing has is that
you know people who come kicking and
screaming into therapy don't know what
they're you know how amazing and how
incredible it is to peel the layers of
the onion off of your own life story
right right and when you do that man you
can have you can have some if you have
such a huge impact on humanity and
society as a whole if you just you know
the peace I think that that is the key
to all this is vulnerability right how
vulnerable can you be how raw can you be
and you know I do tons of speaking in
elementary and junior highs in high
schools and I tell kids don't listen to
the noise because the know
ace has nothing to do with you the noise
has everything to do with them right and
how they're feeling it has absolutely
nothing to do with you that's what I
tell Gary every time he doesn't hear
applause after his jokes I know I
attention to the silence Gary well hey
clouds right it's that not good enough
sign we always pick up the not good
enough sign right because we think that
we're not good enough wolf god like this
is good enough what we're doing is good
enough yeah you know it to add you know
when he talked about the legacy I mean
that was a big reason why it's called
Victor walk and that Theo walk you know
is begin and why did the frog that you
know that we're wearing is is Victor the
Frog you ever seen a frog hop backwards
no can look to the left it can look to
the right but it's always going straight
ahead and that's you know that's why we
chose the frog right you know is that
there's there's one frog I guess that
hops backwards but other than that every
frog always rattles forward right but
you know there's lots of symbolism and
everything that we you know that we do
and and you know there's there's an
incredible scene at the end of the movie
because you know I I do tons of work in
the Aboriginal community in Canada and
we got invited to the Sundance which is
like one of the most sacred ceremonies
in all of Aboriginal culture and the
scene at the end of the movie will
absolutely blow your mind and for us to
get invited to that because at the end
of last year's walk we ended up in
Siksika which is the community where I'm
a honorary chief and they've they've
adopted me into their community and and
we ended the last year's walk at this
and we all got her we had this
incredible traditional ceremony where we
all got our faces painted and it's just
now that's great it's unbelievable so
I'm excited to see it I will definitely
be there I'm really pumped and and
you're an incredible conduit to he
and little did I know watching you out
on the ice as a as an agent of chaos to
me sitting here with you today I would
refer to you as dr. Theo Fleury because
you have a doctorate in life and it's
amazing the gift that you're the gift of
vulnerability you're giving everybody
and to you both of you I cannot
congratulate you enough like I'm so
excited to be there tomorrow and do what
I can on our end to be supportive of
this course so Victor walk jun 7th 2 45
at mann's chinese theater that is 6925
Hollywood Boulevard and you will be
doing the Q&A afterwards absolutely and
you'll be walking I believe to manage
Chinese Theater yeah well we're walking
we're always walking well I cannot thank
you guys you guys and congratulations I
shouldn't wait to see it all the best on
this journey forward with this and uh
I'll see ya mario's camp again hopefully
I don't know I don't know after the last
one hi uh I'm getting a little older I
don't hey guys I really do it alright
let's play y'all called fake it till you
make it right
[Music]
you